okay well for people who are joining
this livestream this is a meeting
talking about n-body simulation in
Wolfram language aimed at a future
version of Wolfram language this is
second or third meeting we've had
discussing this topic so let's see we
actually have some runnable code here
let's hope this actually can load in
okay so oh look at that
alright so so Rob is this
production-grade code or is this still
just demo stuff this is still this is
not production very code at this point
it's getting closer that's that's pretty
much the that's pretty much the the
interface we talked about though okay
all right so this so what this did not a
notebook store now how big is it okay
does that work if I say store now seems
to you should you should be able to
reload that okay all right so if I copy
paste this I mean at least copy paste
that will have the complete thing inside
it who knows okay what's an example of
something I can query for this position
magnificent that's very nice so then
then for that that gives the positions
of those two bodies so if I say let's
just see whether this works if I just
say that is insane that is insane that's
what's necessary now to get the
different colors to work okay
well that should be a discussion I think
we have a discussion later today about
missing values in visualizations
actually if people because I know this
one is evaluation was non evaluation
which arguably particularly with a
compiler we
to be more sophisticated about and
that's probably worth mentioning to Tom
or is it crazy is it far out of reach no
I don't think so it's just the opposite
because like without having it there you
don't know what it will be
that's why you need to evaluate it okay
but through values of whatever is pretty
crazy well see that's because the the
position the position thing returns the
interpolating function so you have to
get the arguments to those and so it's
this way but I mean I think in I mean
this particular thing if we say percent
for I mean if we were to say just just
to try to understand the idiom um you
know if we said this /at you know b-1b
to hunt for the hunt
then we get those and we still don't
have functions do we the the thing is
that in terms of this right if you
wanted to say position of T if you could
insert the T in here then you would be
in much better shape you're right and if
you look further down I think that's
some of the the interface we discuss and
I have a bunch of examples of different
different ways you can get some of these
things I mean you know I think basically
being able to do plots and stuff will
give us some more ideas on that from
what I just did to fine what this method
flattened functions that's that's that's
that's supposed to make it so that I
could do it without the evaluate so I
just left them in for now
so it's fun doesn't evaluate but but it
doesn't work right now anyway so it's
it's it sort of try and ignore that wow
this is really cool so this is
symplectic integrated so the total
energy remains fairly constant no this
is just the default the default
integrator for the symplectic one it's
gonna take it's gonna take some more
work but but it is it is going to be
possible
to use it in some sense well the promise
the symplectic so the symplectic
integrator for it to be some puck dick
and conserve the energy it needs to have
constant steps okay oh right adaptive
symplectic integrators not that not that
that that I'm aware of when I asked mark
he didn't he didn't know anything that
we had that that that does that so one
thing we could do is we can you know
with with what we have now we could
basically monitor monitor the energy and
when that seems to be locally changing
we could sort of stop and then restart
with a different step size and we can
lose a little bit of energy that way but
I think that the total loss would be
would be pretty minor but again that
involves another level of development
then they don't worry about that I
thought the symplectic integrator I mean
if we can have a method where you say
use the symplectic integrator if energy
is what you care about as opposed to
find detail of the trajectory then you
might want to choose that right of
course related what are related like if
the energy is not conserved very
important to your trajectory is also
forth I understand but you have no hope
if the adaptive steps are wrong and
you've got this little thing that's
zooming around a black hole it's just
going to be completely wrong even though
it may conserve energy the trajectory
will also do I mean even though the
symplectic integrator is forced to
conserve energy the trajectory will be
completely wrong unless it's adapted for
that you know high curvature thing
around the black hole or whatever if i'm
not mistaken
i'm not convinced because the symplectic
one does not trust with self energy it
also preserves some high are they really
birds right but what but what yeah it's
it's i think we can actually you know
monitor monitor some conserved
quantities in this you know I just did
this experimentally before we can
monitor some of the conserved quantity
for this one
then when that seems to be locally
changing that that gives us an
indication that our step is too large
and then we could go back
we'd have to sort of back up but we'll
use a smaller step for this section but
Mike one other constants of the motion
are not trivially consider its center of
mass no center of mass might not be
conserved either because we have
introduced the coordinates or anything
is that correct
but what else what other constants of
the motion are there that we can monitor
we know fine and then your claim is that
that is not structurally conserved that
would have to be conserved by virtue of
the actual integration I'm not sure what
this means
well I mean there are some things like
if we had reduced coordinates and we had
reduced out the center of mass then it
is not an interesting statement that the
center of mass is conserved right so you
claim it anything that is still there
any combination so so in particular we
could imagine an option that says
monitor these quantities for example yes
yes you would have to know that they are
preserved if you want to because most of
them did change well I understand but
but there for the inverse square law
there are definite ones that are
conserved right for every one of that
first argument yes I mean I don't know
what other ones we have here but what
are the named ones do we have do we have
other named ones well there's the only
other than I've really tested is
gravitation which is the same thing okay
what about van der waals or something
I mean or lennard-jones or whatever I
mean are we imagining that we'll have a
letter Jones a thing called Lana Jones
and does that even make any sense do you
make sense okay but I mean is there an
obvious lennard-jones of artemis 6-12
whatever the values of the vectors of
their powers okay but then I mean people
people go around you know being very
proud of their atomic potentials and
things and we could imagine curating a
collection of some interesting atomic
potentials yes maybe I mean I know we
have some users who specifically study
atomic potentials we've never asked them
for these but if we had those are they
useful or are they I mean people do
semi-classical computations don't they I
mean they're not they're not solve
insurance or equations for those things
isn't that correct I think in more cases
they use something okay okay all right
so then maybe that's not so useful but
but okay but in a case for the
inverse-square case I mean are there any
other potentials are like harmonic
potentials of interest given with you
so we should have that as a named thing
right yeah I have a I have a bunch of I
have a bunch of named things you know
which which we had in the first version
okay potential is that you know which
guys are connected by which Springs
needs to be specified doesn't it and I
don't think we have an obvious way to do
that
like inverse-square you don't get to
shield gravity by making sense yep but
in the case of Springs some things are
connected and some are not so as I say
did we address that or not no we did not
address that okay
well we should address that I mean I
think that would be some kind of thing
where we say harmonic arrow and then we
give some sparse array which gives the
spring constants does that make sense
because those seem to be though silent
well yeah that's so that's gonna be
that's gonna be a matrix the bodies
which indicates the spring constant
between little bit the edge body flavor
generate case of anybody you're right
I mean are we committed well I don't
know I don't know I mean the Fermi
pastor Coulomb problem and things was
very mean that was intended to be an N
body like thing well maybe maybe I mean
it's an interesting idea you bring up
maybe maybe there should be a way of
specifying you know that the
conventional potential function you know
by some constant for that is specified
by matrix or something that could be
that could be interaction constant
between well I thought we told you no we
did not talk about that okay because I
mean it can take in the mass the
position etc even the velocity it can be
a velocity dependent potential
potentially yes so this thing here can
be a function and the function is simply
fed you know the association for each
body correct right
that doesn't that doesn't that that
assumes that that body each body
interacts which he each other body via
that function based on end up being 0
that's what a small array would do right
you see yes that would be a way of
telling that function that it's 0 for
those two bodies I understand but the
other thing we could do is just return
look in the function we could have a
sparse array sir I'm saying right in in
the actual function in the potential
function the value would be something
which indexes into a sparse array make
sense sort of but it's it's hard to see
what the actual definition would be all
right ok let's come to that let's go
down the rest of this but please don't
forget that ok ok ok all right data on
the body B yes we know data at t equals
1 ok ok that's pretty reasonable ok so
what is this that's all the data at t
equals one point two so that's a bit of
an illusion
so that then you're saying if there's an
on string argument you're taking it as a
time value yes and if I just wanted
position here I would say b1 one and
then position is that right I think you
I think it'd be b1 comma position comma
one I don't remember the order sorry
that was my chair cranky
okay so you say if I say this you think
you're gonna get Oh beautiful
yeah and then if you do of one either
curried or otherwise of one I think
it'll give you the position at that time
magnificent yeah well this is your ideas
would intense shouldn't we say does it
make sense to say position equations it
just says equations that's okay I think
no Hamiltonian equations okay and where
did these four variables these come
these are just Q dot formal Q's a former
Q's subscripted with the body name how
is the subscript and unjust with
subscript just four subscript nothing
fancy I may use in the next I can't
remember either subscript I think it's
just subscript and C's or not but so
could I feed these into you know I mean
like this is a two body problem right so
if I take that I should be able to feed
that into D solve and it should be able
to solve it shouldn't it no well D salt
doesn't one one thing is dissolved
doesn't know dot no it's to the
derivative it's just a variable are two
nonlinear forty sauce copies nonlinear
yes not much hope but I mean Newton
managed to solve this
right hit it was a long time ago if if
you wrote it in the right form dissolve
might have a chance but but with a with
a seed
I kept the dot in there because what are
we talking about dots those aren't dots
those are just full there no no that the
dot and then center of the denominator
oh that's that's that's our yeah that
will make it hopeless but diesel right
or dot product exactly because that that
works more efficiently numerically than
using you know it's it's tidier fer
numerix and using normos although normal
should definitely work efficiently to
yes none would work but I see so your
claim is that if we if you put in a
coordinates it might be able to do it
but it has no hope in this form that's
true staring Michael I think there's no
hope because what Newton did was not
getting Q of T he got out of five which
is double implicit with respect to Q of
T oh I see what is the formula for Q of
T it's something employing the elliptic
functions or what is it I'm sure it
bothers it to you in the claws okay so
with a change of variables into action
angle variables or something
right okay it would be a good test case
for dissolve the might be worth rather
it might be worth pointing that one out
to Roger I mean he may take notes
hopeless but okay three body problem
here we come okay so I still don't
understand why you need this big mess
here given that you've got these quite
clean ways to get I mean given that you
can just say if I do data here
fairies zippy I have to say okay so now
if I say data of and what you're telling
me is I need to say the body name like
um what am I saying here one or
something is that right
it's kind of an awkward body name isn't
it because it's going to conflict with
other things if I say data of one how
does it know what to do well it decided
it was a body name if I'd said okay fair
enough well that's cuz that's cuz I
trust see I used I used that I used one
two and three as the names in this case
right if it was one point like I
shouldn't presumably I can't use one
point as a body name bright then it'll
it'll get confused I think it chooses
the body name before the time but that's
potentially let's say one two three will
it work
is it listable over those don't think I
made it listable
okay so if you did make it list of all
that very nice thing would presumably
give you let's see if it works with just
a one there no that didn't work so but
that should work maybe the curried form
will work right I think the great form
might work okay that's fine okay so now
let's take a look at the one two three
comma to position it didn't break try to
try an awl instead of one two three does
that mean may have overloaded that okay
but you should make one two three
overload no okay so that should work as
well okay so yes that's a good idea to
list over right because then that's a
pretty clean thing data all position of
T that's a pretty clean way to get this
out and then what that would return is
hopefully something that parametric plot
could it will
turn a bunch of interpolating functions
of T and then parametric plot will
hopefully do its thing and color
everything happily
alright that's that's why that flatten
functions is there so that if I don't
evaluate it would still work and color
things without that it's not gonna it's
gonna color everything the same why cuz
that's the way it works it shouldn't do
that if you've got look because it
decides to call up beforehand it doesn't
at every evaluation count because some
might be complex how many good values do
I get how many colors do I need -
sometimes - sometimes I understand but
if it structurally has an association
like this why can't it figure it out I
mean it does figure it out
look listen you're gonna do you're gonna
feed it in apart from the evaluator I
don't think it needs anything else I
think the evaluate will be sufficient
it's for pointing out is you have to
have the evaluator it doesn't okay fine
okay so that's quite magnificent and oh
I see these are two body three body
problems in two dimensions yes what the
heck is that oh I see that's very
beautiful Wow okay and this is showing
you can start you could restart you take
the data and you can restart it and
continue further it's pretty funky that
you've got a six there which you know if
you had a six body problem you're six
I get what I'm saying it's gonna get
confused oh no it's it's just an example
of where the time it's integrating - so
if I'd used six point two eight I
understand I'm just saying because if
you take that particular thing is doing
yeah I get it in that case it's not
ambiguous
um okay multi body in 3d
my doing a random points on a sphere
that's just a starting starting
condition what is the default here oh I
see 24 megabytes shouldn't be default in
the notebook um wow these energy things
are very good it's surprising okay if
you looked at just the energy you might
not be quite so happy kids the fact is
its great doesn't save much okay well it
says that it's not getting round off
between those those things okay let's
look at the Sun so I just chose I mean I
sort of picked around our entity stuff
to find initial conditions that's really
cool
and one thing one thing I'll mention and
I think this is it's you know so I think
you know the right person working on you
know functions and stuff I integrated
this with the energy entity stuff so
notice I didn't have to specify the mass
it just automatically goes and tries to
find it if it's not already given hold
on what where is it finding the mass so
you're saying it's using its using the
so so these these things these bodies
are entities themselves right oh that's
in it when it's an entity it goes and
tries to find the properties it needs
automatically oh that's cool that's
really cool
okay and the difference between gravity
and inverse squares that gravity
actually uses the gravitational constant
and units that's very nice Wow
okay so that's the over to the moon
yeah that's yes that's that the bottom
one is the orbit of the moon around me
around the Earth because this thing here
is the moon versus is that correct
that's great cause it actually looked
like okay so that's a bunch of lunar
months now and I haven't checked that
for accuracy or if you can get the
eclipses
we did look at that in you know if you
look at the blog post I wrote about the
Eclipse
I guess who's a help who helped with
that we did a bunch of these in Japan
provided and then for a couple of days
we can explicitly solve equations of
motion and get it reasonable right and
this should be able to reproduce that
those results this code it's more or
less the code I used fine
and I mean all this Helio coordinates I
know we're working on slowly the whole
astral coordinate system business I
don't even know I have no idea whether
zero though is that the first point of
areas or something as the zero I don't
even know what these coordinates really
are it's somewhere a little bit outside
of the tent of the Sun is the center of
the coordinates but I mean how the how
the XYZ coordinates are aligned in space
I don't quite know somewhere on the
ecliptic I bet the first point of Aries
is involved not that I would have any
idea where that is in the sky right so
with this
snacks example shows is that so now I'm
just considering I mean Michael said I
was lacking and he was correct in
examples of how would you specify you
know specify one of these functions so
you you know it allows for an arbitrary
force function and arbitrary potential
function so so this is this is this is
assuming the Sun is fixed and doing the
same thing where I just have two bodies
the earth and the moon with an external
force or potential basically you could
finding potential yeah okay
how's potential is gravity and Sun force
okay force the first body x okay okay I
get it
mm-hm or equivalently you can give that
as it comes out the same which or
accordingly you can give it as a
potential so that some potential is is
given as a potential the gravitational
potential for the Sun you mean you mean
it's a potential as in so whatwhat's
your point that that why are you saying
that so I'm only considering two two
bodies oh I see okay I see I see a fixed
potential so this might be an external
potential I can I don't have a magnetic
field or something right exactly so it
sort of is a demonstration of the
external external potential with with me
now to me me spend too much time
figuring out physics okay and that this
is this is it's what's so that's
basically what we have excellent really
excellent and this is just experiment
you know it's trying to play around with
scalenes and stuff to see if that helped
this is this is the the older older
stuff which I haven't adapted to the new
potentials okay you mean the old to the
new setup of the way I'm buddy
right to the new setup exactly okay this
looks really good let's document it well
so I think I think to make this
successful Steven I mean I you know I'm
I'm happy to continue to be involved and
continued um these all stuff but to
really make it successful we need
somebody me possibly just an intern
who's you know who's who's more of a
physicist than I am to fill out to fill
out some of these functions and
potentials and test them and see if they
work well is that what we need to do
what do we need these fast multipole
things and all that kind of stuff but I
think first we need to try put in a
bunch of potentials and then you know
seeing where that takes us we may well
need the fast multipole stuff and the
fast multipole stuff is definitely
something I'm interested in if if it
proves that we need it and you know I
think I have the understanding and the
code that would necessary to do that so
that would be that would be something
that makes sense for me to do I don't
know why these potentials well let's
okay we can try and find a physicist to
help with putting in these potentials
but I mean how many potentials do we
care about it doesn't really so what are
they I think if you look in the dot M
file you'll probably see the old stuff
which still has the list of those things
but potential potentials we might call
them yes
I think I kept that there was something
about harmonic there let's do a search
yeah these are these are still these are
so only inverse since gravity I did a
new style I tried to put the harmonic
actually in this new style as well so I
don't tell me what's involved and why
isn't it just if you can put in an
arbitrary potential why can't you not
just put these potentials in just with
their functional forms because I don't
know what's functional form form is I
don't know where charge comes in where
mass comes in you know all of
interesting because like all of them are
basically they're kind of they don't
depending upon middle of the body one
more time you know where the charge is
more interesting they depend one more
time on the body but by the way Coulomb
why are you saying soft Coulomb what
wasn't there just a Coulomb potential
here that's for Michael gave me it has a
charge so I mean it's it's it's a
cosmetic difference right between what
I'm suggesting that we have one that is
called Coulomb and that Coulomb instead
of having a mass has it oh I see it has
a mass maybe you have mechanical objects
moving around right so it should have a
mass and a charge for everybody and it's
still point particles yeah right so I
think there should be a Coulomb thing
there shouldn't in the parent of soft
Coulomb yeah of course okay I just don't
see it here okay
so that one is perfectly real harmonicas
absolutely should be there um and
harmonic how is that going to work with
spring constants and things right so
that's a general question how is she how
should we
how should we add parameters in my
opinion like because all that we
physically care really between everybody
I would would trust also make this for
everybody so what do you mean by that so
will be better
you also got hard sphere right hard why
did you have that that hard core thing
okay I mean let's rank them a little bit
Coulomb is clearly important hard core
so hard core has a parameter the ages
which is the parameter is radius mm-hmm
don't we have to say hard sphere or hard
disk or something
because it matters that it's you know
not things shaped like you know
triangles or something like that
noisy form is Hartsfield to begin in
South Korea is it I think so but but so
long as okay so it's got a parameter of
radius so in the harmonic case it's got
a quotes parameter which is the sparse
array of spring string con spring
constants am i right it depends a little
bit like what you see as a physical
realization of it if you do the little
immediately Springs like family posture
Coulomb then obviously yes what else
might I think I mean other than with
quarks or something I don't know what
has you know everybody interacting
harmonically for instance yes okay but
that's a I mean it's it's not a very
useful
model so if we're gonna do that it's
extremely useful models for for modeling
exchange correlation stuff because you
can solve it fair enough
okay do we care about linear potential I
mean in quantum mechanics we probably
would right that's the thing that gives
Airy functions
yes let's show me this equation and it's
a reasonable model back in the day at
least it was a reasonable model of the
quark own iam energy levels that's what
that's what Rob needed to hear was about
qua Konya might be further I bet you did
hear the word qua cone iam at some point
in your life I probably have okay so
those all seem real I don't know what
what is soft Coulomb do to get rid of
two thing you daddy
so is there a soft gravity as well that
probably should be a soft inverse-square
it would be the natural generalization
of course then you could also basically
make the soft the softness and body
dependent power middle no I understand
but by the time you're doing that you
might as well just specify so what
happens in this setup if you want to
specify the potential between every pair
do we have a way to do that yes we have
a way to do that because you're
basically feeding in what what is the
potential function so we say n body what
are we calling it now and body
simulation yes okay so the first
argument what is the structure of the
first argument when it's basically doing
everything by hand if you can either
just give it a string like gravitation
or you can give it a you can give an
association which is
okay which had the pair potential
function right right okay so we probably
should be supporting you know pair
potential okay so now the question is in
the case of pair potential what does it
what does that take
that what that takes is every so the
function f there and I don't know
whether it needs to be an association
but let's assume let's put it in one for
now so that F takes as an argument if
I'm not mistaken body 1 and body 2
information right the association's for
body 1 and body 2 if I'm not mistaken
that's right
okay I wonder if it needs to know the
names I see I see you can always put
tags and those body 1 and body 2 things
so a typical form for that would be I
mean this is not that uncivilized a
typical form for this would be hash
position well what is this this would be
a second so what would this look like
I'm just trying to understand what it
give me hash one of you know right
exactly
okay alternatively it could be yes okay
hash one quotes position - hash two
quotes position if you look at like
through the inverse square one that's it
that's a good example I think absolutely
nicely so maybe here's an idea for this
parser a thanks even that's that's quite
general is is you could have you could
have say pairwise interaction or
something that I mean just maybe it's
not the right name but you could give a
sparse array to indicate which pairs
which pairs interact with which others
look the only here is that you don't
know the name of the thing you're
dealing with okay you've got hash one of
mass you know you've been already fed
the body specifications but they don't
include the names if they included the
names
right if if what you got was a thing
where it also had named arrow blah
position arrow blah well it will get
that if it has a name if you've given it
a name but so then then in that case all
you do is the potential is just given by
I mean obviously it's somewhat
inefficient to go looking up all the
zero potential you know all the zeros
here but there's certainly nothing wrong
with you know matrix mat of hash of hash
one name comma hash to name that looks
up the coupling constant effectively in
that matrix what that would have to be
instead of name that would have to be
something like index or something if
you're actually talking about a real
matrix you can make a lookup table fine
and fine fine fine
well I mean actually yeah right so it
could feed in it could be that the that
appended to that Association is an index
and if you wanted to you could look that
up so make any sense or is this kind of
stupid idea I mean the alternative would
be yeah look an alternative approach
would be this can mean look if pair
pretentious and then give a list of all
relevant ones those are the ones which
we include yes that would be perfectly
reasonable as well yeah that would be
reasonable potential list
and then what would it look like it
would be an association where the left
hand side is the pair and the right-hand
side is the is the potential yo whatever
it is but then okay with then that
potential I see but but how does that
work is that a function yes it has to be
a function which depends on again hash
one and hash two which are right right
yep
yeah that's perfectly reasonable that's
a single pair potential function and
this is a pair potential list I like
that okay the only table becomes if you
give pose then we have to decide which
way oh I say the pair potential list
wins I think to do well actually you
know what you can have both of them the
pair potential list wins but for any
given pair if it's not in the pair
potential list it defaults to the pair
potential so for example it would be you
know maybe I mean you know presumably
these just like sparse array these
things could be to be patterns okay okay
well I mean basically they'll have to be
processed presumably what you mean there
instead of 4 or 5 would be a you know a
body name right yes right so you have to
do a match which we can do in an
association yeah okay I mean the
relevant case would be a linear chain
and lettuces well you interact with
neighbors okay
yeah that's a good that's a good example
mm-hmm
so an interesting question here
it's whether we can have a named
potential which is a lattice potential
right does that make any sense
could we call it lattice actually we
could mean by this harmonic lattice for
example well harmonic chain is fairly
obvious what that means if there's an
ordering to the elements harmonic chain
just means everybody gets harmonic you
know atomic force with respect to their
neighbors but then we must need an esse
to specify our big the neighborhood is
well I can default one but I mean that
would give us that would give us a lot
of standard you know that that should I
mean okay would give us fbu yes right I
mean if it was not only our at least ok
so here's an interesting question
you know connection to molecule because
one thing we would like to be able to do
is to see take a specification of a
molecule and say ok great let's run this
and body thing with respect to that
molecule can we discuss something just
this morning miss Jason we at least for
now we don't have a decent force field
over in the molecule all those force
fields are hard to get exactly right I
mean you know people have atomic
potentials I don't think they have I
mean for you know for your for your
isolated xenon atom or something as I
understand it right when people do
bose-einstein condensate calculations
and things don't they have potentials
for individual like xenon atoms and
things yes yes
and are those calculations
semi-classical classical quantum
mechanical okay okay so which of these
potentials like your car were potential
where is that going to show up not
quantum mechanic place so to speak and
by the way let me ask this question in a
world of the future could we imagine
doing this for our equations no
absolutely hopeless because the
dimensionality of the Schrodinger
equation scares this the number of
particles and absolutely hopeless even
solving the Schrodinger equations in
independent variables
I understand but in the case you know if
we were trying to do the helium atom for
example okay people do this study
classic aviation is stuff I understand
those are just killing ground states
right you're saying even getting the
Dyne the dynamics okay so for how many
particles can you successfully do
dynamics with Schrodinger equations
three four one two one one in a
potential for example I mean that's been
easy for a long time one and a potential
has been pretty easy for a long time but
this is why many pretty techniques have
been invented so that we don't have
explosion in variables no I understand
but I understand because we got
functions instead of other things that
we have to have to compute the wave
function and so on yeah but just so I
understand okay so the the one particle
Schrodinger equation in a potential well
understood I mean I certainly solve
those things in seventies right there
okay two particles in simply
cases numerically doable okay three babe
basically slowly end of story
okay in the two particle case just out
of physics interest what is the is there
are there does the does the exact solve
ability of a classical to body problem
have a consequence in the shoulder in
the quantum mechanical case or not good
question I don't think so I can't say
for sure but I don't think so
interesting so okay so your basic point
is I mean by the way I mean we could
imagine you know we could imagine
packaging and maybe that's actually
robbed probably knows I mean in the
whole thing that I've been pushing for
like 15 years now of you know PDE
special functions do we have those now
finally coming for some of the common
equations what what what we're doing is
we're working on something Oliver has an
intern who's working now to put together
you know basically taking named
equations and putting together you know
putting together you know more examples
different things you can do with that
equations so much the we are we going to
let you feed a named equation into nd so
I think with what he's doing we may be
able to do that at some point in the
future but the problem is there's so
many you know just like like he's doing
the wave equation now
okay there's so many different different
scenarios you use that in I understand
but the equation itself is always the
same I actually have to type in the del
squared you know Phi equals right I
think that's something that's something
but but then you know how are we gonna
you know where are we gonna specify the
parameters I mean you know it's got the
the C I mean do you
what we should do is we should have a
function called you know we should just
have something called wave equation
kernel and you know you feed it in Phi X
T TX is that crazy
doesn't seem crazy taking your meaning
into stuff that you don't I understand
which is not what we want
okay wave equation wave equation
equation wave equation function and that
returns the idea would be that would
simply return you know Phi TT basically
Phi TT equals Phi xx mm-hmm except of
course for the wave equation we also
need a speed right there was point we
need there's not surprise I mean do you
have a do you have a do you have a
constant density do you have a changing
density do you okay so let's imagine
that we have a thing just like okay
let's imagine that we have a cone right
we hopefully why doesn't produce typeset
form here do you know I don't know okay
so but but what does that it's really
weird but I mean what I'm asking is how
do I give the parameters to that cone
okay outer layer which is the power
noodles may make poverty Association and
you see it exists for that cone yeah for
those cones I'm entering argument
what the heck is that
do I want mathematical solid what do I
want seem so face was fine I thought but
it tastes it evil failure didn't say it
doesn't know well this is eleven point
four so who knows who knows let's just
try this it a more civilized version
okay but what am I gonna see I'm gonna
see some pure functional pure function
in some of them and out of one four
parameters of the code and in inner one
for XYZ okay so what you're basically
telling me is that the right approach
here would be for Rob and Oliver and
friends to basically curate the
equations and put them into a form like
these okay this is much more civilized
Rober you seen what I'm saying I think
so so rather than just having them be
examples have them be computable things
because they are you know so that was
just a bug from um what is in there
Foster for me but it gives nice result
57 of them apparently intercity it said
for me forty nine Sushma you involved in
the the crazy yes the loading thing the
blue has changed and shouldn't oh it
shouldn't it should be the same blue
that we just very light blue okay okay
okay can you try to push that today and
if there's a problem let me know like
look for defining inequalities that this
shows it beautifully
you see just a into H for the radius and
the height and did you know one other
way wait wait wait
well this one here okay implicit region
no that's what is not a good one doubt
when they in darkness yeah are you
typical that is nice that is nice right
so you can put in my variables you want
and and so that would be a good way to
represent equations I am convinced
because like for this one it is nice in
one sense but what I don't like so much
is that we fix the order and for some of
the equations like some of the elastic
mechanics which are literally hundreds
of power meters have an association it's
hopeless but there's nothing wrong with
that i mean the variables the the
independent variables as opposed to the
parameters are fairly small and number
hoping that we only live in a you know
three-dimensional space and stuff like
this
yeah mm-hm but the parameters should
surely be fed in through an association
I agree could be long and messy um I
think this is the right kind of way to
do it and I I mean for goodness sake
don't just have non computable examples
Rob right I see what you're saying it
should be in a form like this talking of
such things Michael and then we should
wrap this meeting are we ever going to
get the coordinate systems we are really
really I mean we had some of this
interim he was really really really good
but he didn't get his extension to be
allowed to work so we were trying to
fixing it up okay but so and there's
there a top level design for how all the
stuff will work no this is no this is
all entities this was in the entity
framework that
basically a pretty faithful
transcription for moon spends on a
classic book on coordinate systems of
Smokies mr. Wonka beat many obviously
all of them are left-handed and we are
right and there's a certain kind of
tension what what wait wait wait wait
wait wait that states first statement is
what do you mean we're right-handed the
determinant of certain things give +1
roses minus 1 but the determinant of the
unit vectors XYZ
yeah gives what for us that's the
right-handed coordinate system for us
once and in that book they gave - they
used - one for them but many of the
curvilinear ones we'll find so that
obviously should be fixed presumably I
mean unless they had a wheel that's not
so obvious is causing this is something
to have
well yes but also maybe we just call it
left-handed ellipsoidal whatever exactly
were working on ok ok
but defaulting - I see so you're you're
proposing so one question is what -
default - what's an example - the book
okay what's an example of one where they
had it left handed over these features
what yeah what is it
Oh spherical coordinates there yeah well
which way is it for the earth but this
depends on you in which order do you do
fi antenna black long I mean that's what
we've done for geo position right is
that long
yes but then we have we have lot long
and then potentially height so we have
height at the end which obvious also a
minus one oh gosh
okay it's it's not a theoretical problem
than a practical one why do you say that
because how often do you run into this
problem that the orientation of your
coordinate system really it's a big
problem but and you calculate the way
you make a picture and it really doesn't
matter much in which although you're
causing it's game fair enough okay
interesting okay
another twist not expected all right
well look in terms of the n-body stuff
it's looks really good Rob I mean let's
try and get it into at least um you know
let's I mean even in the form you have
it it's already useful so let's try to
get some version of it documented I
think the design is fairly good
I take the point about getting more
potentials but you know it would already
be useful just with gravitational stuff
in it yeah fine I mean one one final
question is how do you want to you know
so if we have these named potentials you
know it's moves can be added I mean how
do you want to specify parameters for
those I think the rule so you put in a
list with a rule aim parameters so what
I would say something like harmonic
young arrow spring constant arrow three
that kind of thing
do you agree Michael yeah I think some
potentials
some forces are not generated from
potential so we should be able to give
two forces straight just making sure
because I don't think we discussed our
example today no we didn't but I mean
parents right something like that
I called them pairwise but well no no
that's that's good I was yeah call it
pairwise potential and pairwise force
Michael any comments on that seems okay
to me
though seems to be fine right now I had
I had vertical potential and maybe maybe
external potential I think you said
would be a better name Michael I think
external potential is a better name yeah
yeah I'll change to external then fine
so I'll make I'll make some of the
processing changes particularly to
handle this list thing but the external
one thing that would be nice and I'm not
sure how easy this will be maybe you use
the same trick that you used for the hop
core to confine everything in the box
well what you mean to specify an
external potential that is that is
infinite outside of this and civil
inside which which isn't a quick
potential for numerix obviously but
what's your point how would you specify
that that's what should happen it
partially yes well no no how would you
specify that that's what should happen
but it should be in a box now it would
be something like external potential
goes to if norm of position greater than
one infinity but I'm not sure if that
will probably not work out of the box in
Adi salt used about which box we talked
about I mean I can do like a large
barrier or something Michael that's easy
enough to do you know what I mean like
you're totally free and you reach the
end of your room and then you get hard
reflected yes that's not that works but
you know I can do something take those I
mean an optimization people typically
use these logarithmic barriers which
which you know is this is really a
pretty good smooth mimicking for that
well okay so one thing one could imagine
is it's Coulomb potential but it's in a
box I mean the other one where that
might be much harder to implement for
you would be been event yeah I mean it's
not plausible was that way too difficult
for these equations yeah I can dad that
could potentially be but but what's the
you know what boy what's the event that
occurs when that happens you keep the
position and you normally combin ends of
the speed one oh that's easy that's
pretty easy I do I'm not in a win win
event you know I could I could certainly
do that give me something a little bit
male you know again I flew with this
physics stuff is not concrete because
you know I spend you know 30 minutes for
something that takes you two minutes to
think of this would be a box everything
inside a region which is a box which is
the shape of a particular region and
then there's coefficients of restitution
and so on there might be too much cuz
cuz again a region stuff really works
and I mean in two and three D that would
be easy to do well that's the case we're
mostly interested in I suppose that's
the case from that would be it that
would be a fine way as long as mean as
long as a region can be discretized
minerally then and then actually the
implementation of that is within reason
a little more concrete on that Michael I
I think you're even better off if you
have implicit region because you inside
and you can quickly reflect okay what
would it look like syntactically to put
a region and how it inside here
I mean one thing we could do a little
bit weird
maybe that's at the end that would be in
the association of force and potential
loss right that's what you're saying so
we see I see what you're saying so we'd
say pairwise potential arrow in the
square region arrow yeah you know some
region be nice to specify that if this
authorized infinity another scatter two
items horrifying yeah this is what this
is what people actually want anyway all
right this is beautiful
that would be magnificent okay so by the
way you're telling me okay so this is
region and and by the way we might
support something like unit below the
unit box is probably already supported
as a simple region I don't know how you
get the unit box but it's probably
pretty easy by the way you're saying
that connection to molecule is hope yeah
basically at least for now we did this
cache it but it's not not for the next
year okay okay this is wonderful
all right something else we need to go
over here and discussions about concrete
things million stuff but but yeah okay
fine terrific all right